The Hunger Games is a series of our
teenagers trying to fight back against
the man the man in this case being a
bunch of adults who really like making
teenagers fight to the death but it
would seem that people are generally
less interested in the conclusion of the
trilogy that turned into four films than
they were in the fighting to the death
carts Mockingjay part 2 has had the
weakest release out of all four films
I'm Lucy and this is your gamespot news
update it's rare for a film that debuts
with a box office take of more than a
hundred million dollars to be considered
a disappointment but that was the case
with the release of the much-hyped
hunger games mockingjay part to this
weekend the massive success of the
previous films meant that the
expectations were pretty high for the
final installment which made 101 million
dollars over the weekend unfortunately
as far as opening weekend earnings go
this was still 20 million dollars behind
Mockingjay part 1 and nearly 50 million
dollars behind catching fire as deadline
reports the thirty five percent decline
in revenue from catching fire can be put
down to a number of factors with one
source suggesting that the dip was
inevitable following part ones reduced
earnings and that the dark somber tone
of the last two films may have put some
viewers off again this is a series where
children fight to the death but
apparently you can get even darker Maps
nevertheless Mockingjay part 2 still
remains one of only 34 movies ever to
open above the hundred million dollar
mark in the US it's taken 247 million
dollars worldwide and as a senior media
analyst at Rentrak told Bloomberg at the
end of the day this franchise will be
pushing in on 3 billion dollars the
overall market place is down this
weekend and has been for the last few
weeks because it's overly crowded and
there are a lot of distractions in the
world he added although Mockingjay part
2 continues the adaptations of Suzanne
Collins novels there's been suggestions
that the franchise will continue past
this point in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly director Francis
Lawrence stated that he would love to be
involved with future Hunger Games Movies
the interesting part of the story for me
is to go back 75 years earlier and seek
out
everything became the way it is he said
in February den of geek quoted Jon
Feltheimer CEO of Lionsgate are saying
that the studio were actively looking at
some development and thinking about
prequel and sequel possibilities and in
July co-star Josh Hutcherson also
revealed during an appearance on Conan
O'Brien's late-night show the Lions Gate
had further plans for the franchise so
did you go and see Mockingjay part 2 in
cinemas are you excited by the prospect
of future Hunger Games films do you
think they're just milking it as well
let me know in the comments section
below I'm Lucien you can find me on
Twitter at Lucy James games remember to
keep it gamespot.com for all your gaming
and entertainment news